hey everyone welcome back to the channel
it has been a while since I've recorded
so I might be a little bit out of
practice one thing you may pick up on is
my stunning goatee which I've actually
developed because I was getting hit on
by too many baddies at the gym it was
getting distracting so you know had to
Nerf myself but uh it's a Saturday
morning it's snowing outside and I've
got nothing better to do than talk about
some systems design so let's go ahead
and get into it today we're going to be
building a rate limiter all right so a
rate limiter what is it due what is it
meant for
uh let's go ahead and quickly provide an
example here is myself let's imagine
that I am feeling like my YouTube videos
aren't getting enough views because
they're cracked so I go and watch my own
video times a th000 I literally just
open up a bunch of tabs on my browser
I'm logged in and I go watch my own
video a million times and all of these
are resulting in me getting another view
well YouTube doesn't want me to do this
because not only does it have to pay me
ad revenue for all of those but also
it's just incorrect so they say to me
guess what buddy uh you can't account
for all of those views we're actually
going to stop you from watching even
more videos now this is a kind of
convoluted example because I don't
really think they would rate limit your
viewing but they might rate limit
certain other endpoints the gist is
eventually the server is just going to
be like hey you've done this too many
times you need to take a break we'll
tell you when you can do it again so the
API is going to respond with like no you
can't do it you're getting rate
limited cool so let's outline some
formal problem requirements now that
we've gone through that so number one is
that we basically are going to be
building a rate limiter that's going to
stop bad users malicious ones or
potentially just negligent ones from
submitting too many requests like I
mentioned that can easily bring down
your service you want to stop this from
happening uh it can add extra load on
your service too additionally this rate
limiter should introduce minimal latency
meaning we want to make it as fast as
humanly possible every request tested go
through this rate limiter and as a
result of that we really don't want to
be introducing a ton of extra latency
here it is going to kill our user
experience if we do
another thing is that there are a
variety of different rate limiting
techniques let us try and support at
least a couple of those now for what
it's worth at least from what I
understand there are some pretty
complicated raid limiting algorithms uh
I'm not really going to go into anything
too crazy here simply because uh I just
don't think that's what fits in a
systems design question if you get cut
and in SDI because the interviewer is
like you need to describe token bucket
rate limiting um I don't know seems dumb
to me I feel like it's more so about the
actual architecture of it rather than
the algorithms but but uh we'll do a
couple okay so let's do some quick
capacity estimates because this is going
to be relevant in terms of whether or
not we need to actually partition out
our system so let's imagine we've got a
billion users that are using our rate
limiter I mean that would be great if
our site had a billion users and imagine
that we had 20 different services to
rate limit so when I say 20 services
that could be endpoints they might be
authenticated or non-authenticated so it
might be the login endpoint or the
create user endpoint but it could also
be something like uh you know make a
post endpoint or read a comment endpoint
so let's imagine that for every single
user ID that's like a long so that would
be 8 bytes and then additionally if we
want an integer to keep track of how
many requests a particular user is
submitted that would be four bytes now
in reality we're probably going to need
more metadata than just a single integer
to keep track of request counts but I'm
just trying to get a general estimate
here so assuming that we multiply all of
those things together right we've got a
billion users for each user we need to
keep track of their count of requests
for 20 services and then for keeping
track of those counts we need about 12
bytes that means at minimum we're
probably looking to store at least 240
GB of data so keep in mind that we want
to have minimal latency here uh if we
were thinking about an in-memory
solution 240 GB is probably too big to
be storing on one node there are some
you know servers in memory that have 256
GB uh but again this was kind of an
estimate you'd really be pushing it if
you did that so again if we are planning
on storing things in memory we're likely
going to need to partition out our
server okay so now we've got a more
general question which is what do we
actually want to perform rate limiting
on and we've got really a couple of
options here at least that make sense
you know you can perform rate limiting
on anything but uh it's probably better
off that I'm not performing rate
limiting on uh like the actual type of
requests that you're making and more so
something about you as the user so
option number one would be the user ID
uh the good thing about this is that
it's pretty easy to track it's probably
being passed in every single uh request
um and that you know if we have a
malicious user we can block them that
being said said it's not perfect right
if I'm a user at home and I create many
accounts well the rate limiting on one
user ID is now not going to work as well
you know I will basically be able to
submit as many requests as I have
accounts additionally not all services
need authentication so if I have a login
request and someone wants to DS that by
just spamming it a million times I have
no user ID to rate limit that on because
they're not logged in they're trying to
log in they're using the login service
so I guess the fallback option would be
the IP address so the nice thing about
this is that you know if someone is
creating a bunch of accounts over the
same network uh it's easy to track um
and in addition it doesn't require being
signed in uh for actually rate limiting
a given endpoint um the bad issue here
is that you can have false negatives
basically saying uh I'm going to rate
limit you but you know I've done nothing
wrong and it's my brother on my internet
who's you know being the bad actor so
you don't always want to have to
throttle that person but it's perhaps
better to be safe than sorry here so
sometimes you do likely want to use IP
address
so uh ultimately I think something like
a hybrid approach makes the most sense
where you use the IP address of a user
on non-authenticated endpoints and then
the second year logged in you can go and
use that user ID endpoint so hopefully
that makes a bit of sense let's quickly
describe a rate limiting interface so
the the gist that I mentioned is that we
may have multiple rate limiting
algorithms of how we want to limit the
number of requests the user can make uh
because they're going to have different
implementations what is the interface
that actually describes how it works so
it should be pretty simple for the most
part we've got uh this function rate
limit which is going to return a Boolean
which will be true if the request should
be throttled or rate limited and false
otherwise uh that's just going to take
in a user's user ID their IP address the
user ID I suppose could be nullable
right because of it's a
non-authenticated endpoint you're not
going to have that uh an IP address a
service name so this would be like I
don't know uh make post because every
single endpoint should probably be rate
limited separately I suppose you can
make the argument that you can rate
limit a user you know all at once but I
think it makes sense at least for now to
uh do it separately and then also a time
of the request because typically we're
performing rate limiting on the actual
amount of time between requests uh I
suppose that if it's a service where
like you have an API key and you just
want to stop them from making a certain
amount of request total uh because you
know they've run out of request tokens
or something like that that would be a
little bit different but uh I'm assuming
this is all going to be time
based okay so another question now that
we have to ask ourselves in terms of uh
discussing architecture here is where
within our system does the rate limiter
go so again uh we do have a load
balancer right and I'm assuming for now
that the load balancer and the rate
limiter are separate entities however uh
it is possible that if we want to make
minimal Network requests we could
actually put our rate limiter on our
load balancer right well maybe not
because we mentioned that the amount of
data that we need to store is probably
going to be too big to keep in memory
thus making it in feasable for our load
balancer could we put it on our load
balancer hard drive maybe but then now
you all of a sudden you have a dis
access and that could potentially be
very slow you don't always want that so
option number one is we could perform
the rate limiting locally on every
single service that needs it so imagine
we've got like uh you know a make post
service and then uh I don't know like a
get comment
service you would actually store in
memory some data about all of the
requests that users have made so that
you can go ahead and perform rate
limiting locally on the server so that's
option number one and number two is
going to be the dedicated distributed
rate limiter so that would be rate
limiting basically as its own layer in
our system so we'll talk about the pros
and cons of both starting with the local
rate limiting so I'm going to just call
this service local rate limiting I don't
know if it's a real term I'm making it
up right now so uh maybe don't use it in
your interview but uh hopefully it makes
sense so the pros of this should be
somewhat clear which is that there are
no extra Network calls required
because all the rate limiting is done
right here on our service we can just
keep that data locally and as a result
of doing so we are in good shape okay so
no extra Network calls however uh there
are some cons besides the fact that you
know now you don't have to actually
manage a distributed rate limiting layer
number one is that if we're getting
spammed over and over again and this is
a really big Point those requests are
still making it over here to the service
right and so that's going to use up a
bunch of network bandwidth we don't have
a separate layer area that's kind of
eating up those requests and making sure
that they don't get put on our
service okay so that's one aspect of
things which is that you know we can use
up the server Network bandwidth another
one is basically that um our application
and the actual rate limiting scaling are
tightly coupled so what I mean by this
is let's say that uh this amount of
storage right here is not
enough so we need more rate limiters
right I'd now have to create a second
replica of service one
service one replica
2 just to store all of the rate limiting
information and to be honest that might
necessarily uh that might not
necessarily be useful because who knows
we might just not need uh that much
capacity in terms of dealing with all
the service one requests it just so
happens that uh because of the the need
to be able to rate limit that uh we have
to scale it out a little bit more than
necessary which is not necessarily that
useful and lastly of course um if one of
these guys were to go down we lose the
rate limiting information with it which
is not the end of the world you know the
user can just make new rate limiting
request when it comes back up but it is
worth noting that that happens as
opposed to a dedicated distributed layer
so let's go ahead and talk about that
what would that look like so here we
would have our load balancer and
basically on every request we would
first reach out to the rate limiter the
rate limiter would say okay this request
looks good I'm not rate limiting it and
then number two would be we actually
reach out to our service so what are the
pros and cons of this type of approach
well the biggest Pro is that we actually
Shield our application servers from
large bursts of network traffic right if
I'm spamming spam spam spam what's going
to happen is the rate limiter instead of
saying okay is going to say no you're
not getting through and then there's not
going to be any part of this we're never
reaching out to our service now of
course these are still going to hit the
load balancer which is shitty but uh
eventually there's not really much you
can do about that so again that's one
aspect of it and then another thing is
that we scale this down up uh up or down
independently so if I need more space
for my rate limiting
information I can just do that rate
limiter rate limiter rate limiter and I
can you know partition these by users or
something and our load balancer can keep
track of which uh rate limiter to
actually reach out to so again that is
totally doable and then now you know we
can only keep one instance of our
service we don't necessarily have to you
know make four of them so of course the
bad part of this is that now all of a
sudden we have to make an extra
networking call to our rate limiter and
that is going to slow us down we don't
want that well what could we potentially
do to make our life a little bit easier
one thing that we could possibly do is
actually doing some caching and where
would we do it well in a place that is
going to allow us to avoid an extra
networking request which in this case
would maybe be the load balancer so what
could we do well basically we could have
the load balancer effectively be a right
back cach and what I mean by that is
that after a certain point the load
balancer basically Acts as a partial
rate limiter itself but just not for
every single user ID only for certain
popular user IDs so maybe if we have you
know a rate limit of
10 what we could say is that when the
load balancer receives from the rate
limiter that there is someone who's made
five requests within a certain time
period that it'll actually cash that
value so now all of a sudden it's
storing that I've submitted five
requests as you can
see it's going to store that over here
here we're going to cash it and the next
time when I reach out saying hey can I
make this request it already knows that
I've made five requests it can locally
add such that now it sees I've made six
requests it can say okay and then I can
reach out over here so this will ensure
that certain particularly spammy users
aren't even making their way all the way
to the rate limiter but are just getting
rejected on the load balancer again it's
not really even important that uh all of
the stuff is getting written back to the
rate limiter in our right back hash
assuming there's only one load balancer
if we're using something like an active
active load balancer configuration then
uh you know we may run into a few more
problems and we have to be a little bit
smarter about how we'd actually
partition our requests to load balancers
or something like that uh but assuming
there is just one load balancer this
approach can work very
nicely okay so let's now discuss our
database choice so we know that our rate
limiter is going to be a separate
service right and the question is how
can we basically set this thing up to be
as fast as humanly possible both for
reads and writes because otherwise we're
really going to be slowing down every
single request so the idea is we want
them to be as fast as possible and as a
result we probably don't have time to
access disk when you want to keep things
fast dis really can get in your way so
what can we do we could just keep all of
our data in memory so that would
naturally lead us to either a just using
our own like custom application server
solution or B employing something like
redus or mcast which are both just in
memory databases so um personally I lean
towards using redus here just because
it's got some existing data structures
that we could use like a list or a
hashmap or anything like that and then
also uh as far as setting up replication
goes uh there's not much that we have to
do on our end uh it takes care of a lot
of that for us pretty easy to get single
leader replication going so I personally
am leading towards redus I think if you
want to make the argument for any other
database that stores stuff in memory you
know be my
guest okay so now let's talk about our
replication Choice uh I guess the
question is can we get away with using
something like multi-leader or
leaderless replication here uh that's a
good question at the end of the day we
do need our rate limiter to be fall
tolerant because if one of them goes
down that would mean that all of a
sudden we can't submit any requests to
our service and that is unacceptable so
let's think first about multi-leader and
leaderless replication imagine we have
multiple rate limiters RL RL and
basically you know they're in a
multileader setup where they're both
communicating with one another um first
of all that could increase our right
throughput because now rights can go to
either of these replicas um and
additionally it could even uh decrease
our right load on each of those
databases as a result because um you
know now I just have more places that I
can write at the same time though let's
say uh rate limiter thinks Jordan has
three and this guy thinks Jordan has two
we need some time for them to actually
sync up we have to wait for anti-entropy
and there's not really any guarantee on
when that would happen
another uh aspect of things that we
could do is use a crdt so again this
would be more of like um a version
Vector almost of counts that I've done
so this guy would say I'm replica one so
I believe that I've received three
rights and replica 2 says I've received
uh two rights so basically my count is
two locally and then my count is three
locally over on the left here and then
when they sync up this Vector becomes
32 which is going to indicate that we
have a count of five so that's what a
crdt is it's basically um you know the
idea is that even though locally uh you
know we don't have the right answer when
they eventually sync up with one another
uh they do so in a way that doesn't
cause any right conflicts and we can
actually get the total number of times
that I've submitted a request even still
again I think it would be better off to
just be accurate in our rate liming
Counts from the get-go and the way that
we can do that the most easy is by using
a single leader so again if we just have
a single Master node RL right here and
that's got something like a
follower uh you know if I write to the
master node this is going to be a
synchronous over here to the follower
and then I can always just make uh read
requests from the master node as well
and if this guy goes down then this guy
becomes the
master um now you may be saying well
what if we read from all the followers
we could but we might get stale reads uh
and then you might say well shoot now
the master is going to have very high uh
read load and you'd be correct there but
I guess we could just uh create a
sufficient number of partitions such
that hopefully that isn't an issue so
that is uh my thinking
there but moving on now hopefully we can
get to the actual mey part of this video
which are a couple of the algorithms
that we want to be implementing so I'm
going to be talking about two in this
there's fixed way uh window rate
limiting and then there's also going to
be sliding window rate limiting uh but
you know these are relatively basic I've
actually spoken about how we might
Implement these types of things in our
stream processing video uh so if you
need more detail on this process you can
go ahead and watch that uh but the idea
here with fixed window rate limiting is
basically that we have you know a
certain rate limit let's say it's two in
this example and that it resets every
single uh basically discrete unit of
time so in this case let's imagine that
it resets every single minute starting
from you know like a new clean minute
and going to the next new clean minute
so for example that means that these two
requests are valid now at 101 we reset
so these two requests are valid and oh
shoot this one comes within the 101
minute so so that one we have to rate
limit so to keep this in mind imagine
you know we're storing the following
data structure right we have some map
from service name which is going to be
upload to user ID which is going to be
22 to basically the current time and the
current counter so at 1:00 so far we've
got zero requests so this guy comes in
now all of a sudden we've got one
request at that minute this guy comes in
now we've got two requests at that
minute this guy comes in now we're down
here we have one request again but the
time has now moved up to 101 same thing
for the next guy now we've got two
requests and the time has moved up and
then finally when this erroneous request
comes in or not erroneous but we have to
rate limit it this comes in the counter
gets set to three you can see that that
is bigger than two and so now all of a
sudden we have to actually throttle that
client so hopefully that makes sense I'm
going to go through the actual pseudo
code for it really quick but uh no worry
as if the above just made sense then the
pseudo code doesn't uh you know at the
end of the day you're looking at code on
some guy's iPad it's a lot easier to
just understand running through the
algorithm like before I guess the idea
though is that if we have a user ID we
have our service name and we have the
request time we're basically keeping a
map from service to user ID to a tupal
of basically the current window that
we're looking at and the count of
requests in that window all we have to
do is get our current tupal every single
time a new request comes in once we do
that we check whether the new request is
the same minute as our current tupal and
if it is we increase the count by one
otherwise we're basically going to reset
the current tupal such that the time is
going to be the current minute of our
request time so you know all of a sudden
we went from 1:00 to 101 let's set 101
to be the value of our current tupal
with a count of one and then in terms of
whether we actually want to go ahead and
perform rate limiting here we we better
just check whether the current tupal
count is greater than our limit so in
this case our limit is going to be two
hopefully that makes sense I think uh
it's fairly straightforward for this one
and now we can go ahead and talk about
the sliding window rate liming
so the idea here is if you recall from
our fixed window rate limiting uh you
know if I submit another request right
here this one's totally valid right uh
forget about all these guys on the right
even though it's within a minute of
these other two on the left of it a
sliding window is going to ensure that
it doesn't happen so if I just say in a
sliding window rate limiting situation
all requests uh if if we have more than
two requests within any minute uh we
have to do rate limiting then this will
actually go ahead and solve that problem
so how would we do that well for
starters let's imagine that these two
are valid uh this is like a minute and a
half later so it's valid this guy is
also much later so it's valid and then
even though this guy is not technically
in the same minute it is uh you know
like another 20 seconds later meaning
it's going to be the third request in a
minute and so it is going to be invalid
so how would we actually perform this
type of thing well in this case we want
to use something like a linked list so
let's imagine that first request comes
in right this is going to be number one
over here and so we add our first node
to our link list next another request
comes in and so we also add it to our
link list as you can see that's over
here the next thing that's going to
happen apologies for my coughing is that
we get uh this guy over here and if you
note look at the time
10140 if I subtract a minute from that
uh to
100040 now all of a sudden both of these
two are outside of the active time range
so we actually have to purge them from
our linked list
so now all of a sudden we just have
10140 again 10140 is the only thing in
our link list 10150 comes along which is
this guy we're going to go ahead and add
that because it is within 10 seconds of
whatever is in our link list and then
finally now all of a sudden uh when this
guy comes in which is going to be let's
say I don't know
10210 we'll see that basically 10210 uh
is recent enough that neither of these
guys get expired and then all of a
sudden and uh now if we were to add it
our linked list would be too big and so
we have to rate limit this request and
say no it's not valid so the idea is
that every single time a new request
comes in we first Purge all of the old
requests from the LinkedIn from the
LinkedIn from the link list and then
after that we go ahead and add the new
request to the link
list so just to give some pseudo code to
hopefully explain this a little bit
better the main idea here is that we
first get a cut off time for a given
request which is when the request comes
in minus the actual sliding window size
in seconds or whatever you want to call
it and then basically the next thing
that we're going to do is look at our
linked list and say hey while the head
of the linked list is earlier than our
cut off time go ahead and remove that so
we're purging our linked list so that we
only have things from the last uh minute
in there and then the last aspect of
this is basically figuring out whether
the remaining entries in the link list
are already uh bigger than our rate
limit and if not we can go ahead and add
our new request to the link list right
so that's where we would do this we
would push our tail and then finally we
would basically just say return whether
this thing was too big or not and
that'll tell us whether we've hit our
rate limit so hopefully that part makes
sense the idea is basically just step
one purge old
entries step two add new
request to linked list if it's
valid if it's not valid then that means
that there have already been too many
requests in that sliding window and you
can just throw this one out and then
when a minute finally does pass that you
have more room a new request will work
uh you could make the you know design
decision to actually just add it
nonetheless regardless of whether it's
valid or not uh but then that would mean
that you know say if every single 30
seconds I try and submit a new request
and I have a one minute limit then I'll
never be able to get any requests
through as opposed to just one out of
every two of them so hopefully that
makes sense cool so another aspect of
this is whether or not we have to
consider any concurrency or threading
considerations uh the idea here is yeah
we probably do the reason being that uh
we have a lot of potential for race
conditions right so keep in mind that in
our uh basically our fixed window
algorithm we are reading a counter and
we're uh we're incrementing it and so
unless we're doing this type of thing
atomically uh which to be fair we can
but it requires is locking we have the
potential for lost updates right so lost
updates would basically mean that one
thread comes in tries to increment this
guy so it breeds one and increments it
to two and then another thread comes in
and tries to increment this guy and it
doesn't see the fact that uh you know
the thing has been incremented to two
yet and so it's also going to read one
and incremented to two and now the
counter should have been incremented
twice but in fact it only gets
incremented once and that is going to be
a problem so of course the way we would
solve this is performing some sort of
locking on this count counter or just
running single threaded uh which is
unfortunate but there's not really any
way around it another thing to note is
that for the actual sliding window
implementation uh we need to be careful
with our link list with a link list you
can definitely have concurrent
modification exceptions the reasoning
being that if I'm trying to add a new
thing to a link list and it has to point
to existing elements in the link list
well crap now I can have two threads
adding elements that point to what they
thought was the head and so as a result
of that we are in a bit of trouble we
have to per form some locking on our
linked list in most modern languages
there are concurrent linked list
implementations and we would probably
want to be using one of those blocking
versions so uh this also applies to link
list deletes too because it you know it
becomes a matter of well if I'm trying
to delete the first element and you're
trying to delete the first element shoot
we might actually delete the first
element twice and who really knows what
that behavior is defined as so uh as far
as I can tell I don't think there's a
good way around avoiding you know either
doing things in a single- threaded
manner or using locking uh it's just
what happens when uh you know you have
data structures in memory that you need
to be able to increment uh so such is
life finally we're almost there because
my voice is really starting to kill me
I'm sure you guys can hear it a little
bit we are going to do our rate limiter
design now this one is going to be very
simple because you know most of the work
here was really well where do we put our
rate limiter what's the code that we run
on our rate limiter uh what do we
actually do with our rate limiter uh so
the main idea at least in my mind is
we've got some big beefy load balancer
right here it has a rate limiter cache
for all of those requests which are you
know becoming more and more common place
if I'm a particularly bad actor ideally
we want that stored in the rate limiter
cache so it doesn't actually have to
ever reach our rate limiters over here
but basically the idea is we've got a
bunch of reddish partitions all of which
are doing single leiter replication
hence why we see these backups right
here and then of course what's that
going to do is uh you know first we
request our rate limiting service once
we receive a response we then go ahead
and request our backend service assuming
that we didn't get R limited so
hopefully the design is simple enough
anyways guys as always thank you for
watching looking forward to a great 2024
with all of you and I will see you in
the next one